The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome to 5.111, and
today what we're going to
do is introduce you to the
course and the people teaching
the course.
And we're also going to let you
know that you were going
to be part of the great web
exercise that is OCW,
OpenCourseWare.
So, this course is being
videotaped this year, and this
is the announcement that
I have to make.
So, the videotape is in the
back, and if you want to come
up front and participate in
the class, you know that
you'll be videotaped -- if you
want to hide your face or
whatever, you can do that but
please pay attention to the
lectures anyway.
So, this course will be
available on the OCW site in
the future, I'm not sure exactly
what that date is
going to be.
So, today we're going to
introduce the chemistry
topics, which we will cover in
5.111, and give you general
information, practical
information about the course
number of points you need, when
the exams are, that kind
of thing, policies, and
introduce you to
the teaching staff.
I am, again, Professor Cathy
Drennan, and I'm one of the
lecturers in this course.
So, because this is MIT, we're
going to start to quiz.
OK, not a quiz for points or
anything, don't freak out, but
I do want you to tell me
who these people are.
So, what about this person?
That's me -- this is my college
yearbook photo.
OK, what about this
person over here?
STUDENT: You?
PROFESSOR: It's not me again.
Not Elizabeth Taylor.
It is Lisa Kudrow, known as
Phoebe on "Friends." So, we
both went to college at
the same time, we
went to the same college.
Does anybody know what
college that was?
STUDENT: Vassar.
PROFESSOR: Vassar College,
very good.
And we graduated the same year
-- now no one has to say what
year that was, even if
you know, but we did
graduate the same year.
All right.
So, given what you know about
us, what do you think Lisa
went to college to study?
STUDENT: Computer?
PROFESSOR: Computers?
No.
STUDENT: Theatre?
PROFESSOR: Theatre?
Surprisingly, no.
STUDENT: Nuclear Engineering?
PROFESSOR: Nuclear Engineering
at Vassar, no for
a variety of reasons.
Any other guesses?
STUDENT: English?
PROFESSOR: English, no.
Biology --
I heard it.
Biology.
What do you think I went
to college to study?
STUDENT: Theatre.
PROFESSOR: Theatre, correct!
And/or I hadn't made up
my mind exactly --
biopsychology or drama.
So, biopsychology was what they
called sort of brain and
cognitive sciences
in those days.
So, those were the two things
I was thinking about.
What do you think Lisa ended
up majoring in college?
STUDENT: Biopsychology.
PROFESSOR: Not biopsychology.
STUDENT: Biology.
PROFESSOR: Biology, yes.
What do you think I majored
in college?
This should be a bit easier.
STUDENT: Chemistry.
PROFESSOR: Chemistry, And, of
course, our professions,
actress and chemistry
professor.
So, let me ask what
happened here?
My understanding about Lisa
Kudrow is that she came from a
Hollywood family.
She went to college and said
here's my opportunity to study
the thing that I find most
interesting, and that was
biology, and then she went back
and participated in the
family business, which was of
course the acting profession.
For me, what happened?
Well, I have to say, I did not
like chemistry in high school,
so I did not think about going
to college to study chemistry.
So, why did I not like chemistry
in high school?
I think it was because of
images such as this one.
You spend a lot of time talking
about the transition
between alchemy and
modern chemistry.
I wasn't very interested in
that kind of thing, and
there's nothing in these
photographs that really
appealed to me personally.
I mean, Avogadro --
I'm fond of his number, and he
is, in fact, an interesting,
if not frightening looking
man -- this just didn't
connect with me.
But then I got to college and
they said, "Well, if you're
thinking about anything bio --
biopsychology, biology -- you
have to take chemistry." And I
said to my advisor, "No, no.
I have taken chemistry in high
school, and I can assure you
that chemistry has no relevance
whatsoever to the
life sciences." And they said,
"Well, I'm sorry you feel that
way, it's incorrect, and you
have to take it anyway."
So, I, like some of you in
this room, took freshman
chemistry, because we had to,
not because we wanted to.
And I, like hopefully some of
you in this room, discovered
that chemistry was actually
a lot of fun, and that the
chemistry I got in college was
pretty much nothing like the
chemistry I had seen
in high school.
So, let me introduce you to
some of the topics we are
going to be covering in
chemistry this semester.
So, there's more detail on your
syllabus -- a detail of
what we'll cover every day,
but these are the kind of
basic things that were covering,
and you don't need
to write this down, you'll
become familiar with it as the
semester goes on.
We start out with some really
basic principles.
So, up here, atomic theory,
periodic table, bonding,
structures and molecules.
And there will be a little bit
of history in there, but this
is mostly modern chemistry
and represents the basic
properties of matter, and it's
basic properties of all
matter, including living matter,
which was what really
interested me, that connection
between chemistry and biology.
So, then we go to thermodynamics
and chemical
equilibrium, and this is
really about chemical
reactions -- weather a reaction
will go, will it be
spontaneous, if there an
equilibrium, what direction
will the reaction
be shifted in.
And then, of course, not just
whether the reaction will
occur but, how fast it occurs
is really important.
So, that's kinetics -- how fast
a reaction will go, and
from the perspective of someone
who's a biochemist,
I'm interested in kinetics and
enzyme kinetics, and thinking
about molecules that catalyze
reactions in the body.
And then, there's acid base
equilibrium, and also
oxidation reduction reactions,
and what is true is that most
reactions that occur are either
catalyzed by either
some kind of acid base catalysis
or involve some kind
of oxidation reduction reaction,
and so, this sort of
represents a lot of the basic
way reactions go -- now,
whether that's a reaction in
your body or a reaction in a
test tube -- it doesn't matter,
a lot of the same
principles are involved.
And then, we also cover
transition metals, which is
something that you often don't
see in high school.
And transition metals, those
all medals in the middle of
your periodic table, have some
really unique properties,
which are exploited again in
reactions that occur in your
body, and also are utilized in
industry, for example, so
we'll talk about some of those
unique properties.
And if we put all of that
together, we get the real
fundamentals that you need to go
on and study -- any kind of
curriculum that involves
chemistry.
So, these are all the
fundamentals that are involved
in chemistry that relate to
physical chemistry, organic
chemistry, inorganic chemistry,
biological
chemistry, and are a solid
foundation for studying any
kind of life science.
So, I congratulate you of being
here in this class, this
is really good solid foundation
for whatever you go
on to do, here at MIT.
So, normally at this point, we
do actually start class with a
little bit of history from
alchemy to modern chemistry,
but I decided to skip
that this year.
If you are interested in that,
it's never required on any
test, it never has been, but if
you're interested in that
there is an OCW lecture, which
you can listen to that's an
excellent lecture by Professor
Sylvia Ceyer on that.
But today instead, I thought I
would give you some examples
of modern chemistry -- why
people now need to know
chemistry, what they're doing
with chemistry, what is
chemistry research here at MIT,
and how does it utilize
these basic principles,
which we'll be talking
about in the course.
So, I'll start with
my colleague,
Professor Joanne Stubbe.
She studies molecules, in
particular she studies
biological molecules.
And, so one of the things she's
very interested in is
how this anti-cancer
drug, gemcitabine,
works in the body.
So, it inhibits an enzyme, and
she's interested in knowing
how that really works.
So, enzymes are made up of amino
acids, you have long
chains of amino acids that form
together into a protein
molecules, protein molecules
in your body often act as
enzymes, catalyzing reactions.
So, she is interested in how
this molecule, gemcitabine,
inhibits an enzyme.
So, to do those studies, she
needs to know a lot of the
stuff on this list.
Of course, she needs to know
the basic principles, but
she's also talking about it an
enzyme, so she needs to know
about enzyme catalysis.
She needs to know this enzyme
works by both acid base
chemistry, and oxidation
reduction.
It has two irons that are
involved in doing the
chemistry, so it includes
transition metals.
She thinks about how things
bind, how the natural
reactants binds, how the
inhibitor binds, and so she
needs to know what happens to
the chemical equilibrium, she
needs to know about the
thermodynamics of those
binding events, and, of course,
everything, all the
basic principles, are
required here.
So, to do this biochemistry
research, she needs to know
all of these things, and she
has really made tremendous
progress in understanding how
gemcitabine works, and it is
not so toxic, so it's a really
good thing to have in
chemotherapy.
So, in addition to studying
molecules, chemists often want
to make molecules, such
as Tim Jamison,
who's an organic chemist.
So, you will hear, probably,
hopefully, in this
presidential debate about the
environment and about why
saving the environment
is important.
And one of the things you
often hear about in this
discussion is about our oceans
and about rainforests, and
part of the reason why people
want to protect those areas is
because you find a
lot of natural
products in those regions.
So, a natural product is
something that is made by
nature, and often natural
products, whether it comes
from a plant or a marine
organism have some really
good, useful properties.
And so, one particular compound
has anti-tumor
properties.
So, again, along this line
of cancer research.
So, Tim Jamison's lab figured
out how to make this thing.
And often that's really
important, because you can't
get enough of the organism that
naturally makes it, to be
able to grind that organism up
and have enough that you can
actually use as a medicine.
So, you have to make more of
it, because nature doesn't
make enough.
So, it's very important to
figure out how to do that.
So, in doing that, Tim Jamison's
lab needs a lot of
these things.
So, he needs a lot of knowledge
of bonding, he wants
to form bonds in making this.
He needs to know about the
structures of the molecules,
because if the structure is
wrong it's not going to work.
And often, if you want to make a
lot of it, you have to think
about the thermodynamics of
the system, how fast the
reactions will go and kinetics,
and then whether
they'll go, the thermodynamics,
and sometimes
then you need to adjust the
reactions, maybe use a
transition metal to
make it go better.
So, these are all the things
that Tim Jamison needs to know
to do organic chemistry.
So, you'll be learning in this
class a great preparation for
512, which is organic
chemistry.
In addition to studying
molecules and making
molecules, some chemists want
to detect molecules, and a
chemist who likes to detect
molecules is Tim Swager.
So, Tim Swager's lab has
designed sensors that detect
vapors, and so they will detect
TNT, for example.
And so, he has put this
chemistry to use in this
robotic arm and they call it
Fido, because often dogs are
the creatures that have to go
out and detect these things,
and it's not a great job if
you're a dog to be sent out to
see whether there was an
explosive and discover yes,
there was, a little
bit too late.
So, this is a much nicer way to
detect chemicals with this
robotic arm, and here's a
picture of it in use in Iraq.
So, in doing this, if you go
down to kind of a basic
principles that Tim needed
to know about, oxidation
reduction was really key in
developing this technology, so
we'll talk about that.
So, my final example is from
Alan Davidson's lab, and Alan
is an inorganic chemist -- he
loved those transition metals
and they're unique properties,
and he designed this compound,
it's called Cardiolite, and it's
used in heart imaging.
So, many people have relatives
they know of that have had to
have their heart imaged --
heart disease is a major
problem in the United States,
and there's a good chance that
they had Cardiolite given
to them to help in
that imaging process.
So, this again, takes advantage
of those great
unique properties of transition
metals, which we'll
talk about in this course.
So, again, all together, this
is the basis for modern
chemistry, and examples I just
gave you, are some of the
things that modern chemists are
working on -- some of the
issues that our country faces
and our world faces, and how
chemistry is involved in that.
So, not only will you have the
fundamental knowledge to go on
and take more courses in
chemistry, you will also have
the fundamental knowledge to
go on and do undergraduate
research here, and here
are some of the 5.111
undergraduate researchers that
have come through my lab, in
particular, from this class.
So, it's a really nice
solid foundation.
So, I want to encourage you to
set some of your likes and
dislikes from high school aside
when you come to MIT,
because at MIT you often see
disciplines taught and
emphasize a very different
fashion than
what you've seen before.
And you may discover that the
thing you came here to study
is not the thing that
you really want
to study after all.
One other thing that I'll say
to you is that I said these
words at one point, it's true,
I said, when I was in high
school, I said, "I hate
chemistry." And now, I do
chemistry every day and will
for the rest my life.
I love chemistry now.
Be very careful what you say.
Have any of you made
that statement
about hating a subject?
Tell me later what it is you're
going to be doing for
the rest of your life.
So, at MIT things are very
different, and keep an open
mind, explore new areas -- take
advantage of being at
this amazing place for science
and technology and you may
surprise yourself in what you
really enjoy learning about.
So, that's a little bit about
the chemistry that we're going
to cover in this class, and now
I'm going to talk a little
bit about some of the policies
and procedures.
But first I need to introduce
my co-instructor for this
class, and let me just put
up her picture, you'll
see her in a minute.
So, Dr. Beth Vogel Taylor.
So, all chemistry courses are
team taught, so you have a
different lecturer for the first
half than the second
half, and Dr. Taylor will be
doing most of the first half
lectures, and I'll
be doing most of
the second half lectures.
So, Dr. Taylor will take you
from atomic theory through
thermodynamics, and I'll start
up with chemical equilibrium,
talk to about kinetics, acid
base, oxidation reduction and
transition metals.
So, you will have both of us
as lecturers in this class.
Now, in the past, sometimes
students have found this whole
thing a little frustrating, that
they just get used to one
lecture style, and then all of
a sudden there's another
lecture style, and
that can be true.
I mean sometimes the styles of
the two professors couldn't be
more different -- think
McCain/Palin, odd couples.
Sometimes they're more similar,
and when I first,
about a year and a half ago,
got to know Dr. Taylor, we
sort of realized that we had
very similar styles, and we
got very excited about the
idea that we could teach
together, so that there would
be much more continuity
throughout the semester.
And so, Dr. Taylor had been
teaching the first half of the
material in the Spring, and I
had been teaching the second
half of the material in the
Fall, and we thought wouldn't
it be great if we got together
and taught in the Fall.
So, this was actually, for a
variety of reasons, a very
complicated thing to request
and do, and so we started a
campaign and campaigned for a
year and a half that we should
be allowed to do this course
together, and finally just a
few weeks ago in August -- we
really didn't know up until
almost when this course
started -- that
permission was granted.
So, I have to say, I am very
excited now to introduce you
to Dr. Taylor, who I would be
teaching with this semester --
limited engagement -- who will
tell you about some of the
course policies.
PROFESSOR: Okay, so before we
get to some of these course
policies, I think I'll tell you
a little bit about my path
to chemistry as well.
Professor Drennan explained that
not everyone that ends up
as a chemist started off that
way on their first class
freshman year, for example,
in chemistry.
And in fact, if you talk to a
lot of chemists, if you talk
to some of the graduate
students, maybe your TA,
you'll find that that phrase, "I
hate chemistry," has maybe
been uttered by more than one us
at some point in our lives
before we realized, and once it
happens you don't go back,
that actually you love chemistry
and it's hard to
even remember a point where you
didn't see all of these
connections that it
provided for you.
To give a little background of
where I was, sitting where
maybe you are today on the first
day of chemistry, when I
left high school, I had no
interest in chemistry
whatsoever.
And I have only one strong
memory from high school
chemistry, and that memory is
shown right here, and that is
the common ions.
Did you guys have to learn
the common ions?
Does anyone have that in their
brain somewhere for ready use?
I don't, in fact, so it's
actually okay if you don't
know all your common ions,
if you missed that part.
This is the strongest memory I
have, and I remembered a) that
I didn't learn them, and that
was really bad because it kept
coming up, but the other thing
I remember is that I had no
idea why they were important.
I didn't really understand
what any of
these molecules were.
I certainly didn't understand
how they even connected really
to chemical reactions, much less
other disciplines that I
was interested in.
I couldn't have told you, for
example, if we look at a
phosphate group, that that's
going to be incredibly
important in DNA, that it's also
an incredibly important
group when you're dealing with
proteins and whether you're
turning the function of
a protein on or off.
So really, I just had no context
for the chemistry.
So, when I started in college,
that wasn't even an option for
me and I was interested
in a lot of things,
chemistry not being one.
But one that I was very
interested in was biology, and
the reason was we did a lot of
cool labs in high school, I
loved doing the dissections --
it was very interesting to me
to think about how different
organs worked, how the heart
could be a pump, how
the lungs worked.
And then when we got to more
of a cellular level, it was
even more interesting to see
that we could actually
understand how our body worked
as low of a level as thinking
about cells.
And so, that was a clear
major for me to pick --
I actually also was considering
English and ended
up being a minor in English.
But, I think what most of you,
actually having come to MIT,
have probably realized is
sometimes it's nice to major
in a science, because you can't
just pick up a reaction
and do it in your kitchen on the
weekend, where as you can
sometimes join a book
group and do that.
So, it's kind of nice to major
in the thing that you're going
to get to have the opportunity
to do for the
rest of your life.
So, I actually also
started pre-med.
Is anyone else pre-med here?
Okay, so a pretty
good showing.
So maybe you can relate to some
of the reasons I wanted
to be pretty pre-med -- part of
it was the interest in the
science and the biology.
Also, I wanted to help people
-- it seemed like a really
clear way that I could have a
career that was challenging
and involved in science, but
also helping others.
So, it seemed like a good start
for me, pre-med/bio, and
I signed up for my
bio class --
I found out, as Professor
Drennan did, that I had to
take chemistry as well.
I wasn't as upset, I was sort of
a neutral chemistry person
at this point, but I thought it
was pretty smart to get it
over with on the first
semester, so
that's what I did.
And my plan was going along fine
until something happened,
and what happened was that
chemistry was just way more
interesting than
I anticipated.
So, my perfect pre-med/bio
plan was getting a little
shaken right from the start,
and the reason that it was
getting taken was because I
would learn this new principal
in chemistry and because I was
taking bio with the same time,
I could see the connections.
And at one point I realized,
"Oh, my gosh, chemistry is
just biology, it's just looking
at one level deeper."
So actually, all of my interest
in biology was
quickly transferred to saying,
"Wow, now I can think about
things on the molecular
level." And one of the
molecules that caught my
attention first, and I can't
remember if this was freshman
or sophomore year in high
school, was the first time I
actually took meaning in
looking at a chemical structure,
and that was with
the structure of penicillin
here, and I know that all of
you are familiar with
penicillin, whether or not you
know the structure or not, but
the most important part of
this structure is the
four-membered ring here, the
beta-lactam, and this was the
first time I thought I could
actually understand how a
molecule worked because I knew
something about chemistry.
So, for example with penicillin
what it does is it
inhibits an enzyme that builds
the cell wall in bacteria, the
bacterial cell wall, and if I
thought about what I'd learned
in chemistry -- some of you know
this from high school,
some of you will be very
familiar with this soon, is
that this carbon here,
for example, is
bonded to three things.
Does anyone know what angle
those would like to be at?
120.
They want to get as far away
from each other possible, the
ideal angle is 120.
But what we have here is a
four-membered ring, so what
angle does that have
to be, that bond?
90 degrees.
So, we have a problem here if
we're thinking about keeping
things at the lowest energy,
so there's a lot of ring
strain in the system.
And I was incredibly excited
that I could look at that and
realize it and say "Wow, that's
why it's so reactive,
that's why it's such a good
medication," because when it
comes into contact with these
bacterial cell wall building
enzyme, the enzyme can actually
react with this
four-membered ring and
open up the ring and
relieve that ring strain.
So, now the angles can open up
all the way to 120 if it wants
to, and there's no way it's
going to form that ring again,
right, because it's not going
to back to those 90 degree
angles, if it can help it.
So now, the enzyme is locked
up with the penicillin
molecule, no more bacterial cell
wall being built, and the
penicillin has effectively
killed the bacteria.
So, that, for me, was kind of
the first connection that what
went, "Woah, wait a second, I
want to be thinking about
these molecules all the way
down to the level of
individual atoms." So, at this
point, kept the pre-med, just
switched the major
to chemistry.
The next problem came
up when I went and
took organic chemistry.
So, if you're dead set on
staying with bio, maybe, I
guess you have to take organic,
so this might happen
to you, just to warn you.
We started looking at all
sorts of other kinds of
molecules that became very
interesting to me.
I especially love thinking
about vitamins and drugs,
because I do have
that interest in
medicine and human health.
These are actually all examples
that we'll talk about
in freshman chemistry at some
point, as an example of a
connection between a chemical
principle we learn, and what
we can know about how
it functions.
But what happened here was I
thought "Oh, my gosh, now I
could actually, using my
chemical knowledge, think
about synthesizing these
molecules, or maybe coming up
with new ways to synthesize
them better or synthesize
different molecules.
And the real clincher was when
I started doing some
undergraduate research.
Any potential UROPs out there
-- anyone planning to do a
research at some point?
Excellent.
Okay.
So, just to be warned, you might
fall in love with the
subject you do your UROP in.
This is one of our summer
students from this past
summer, who is also premed.
She's continuing to be pre-med,
which is fantastic.
That didn't happen to me --
once I got into the lab, I
didn't want to leave.
So, I thought, "You know what,
I think I'll change the
medical school plans and now I'm
going to go all the way --
chemistry major, chemistry grad
school." And the reason I
was able to do that and keep
with what my original
intentions were was to have
a career that was the
fulfilling, in terms of helping
people and being
engaged in science, is all of
a sudden I realized, as
chemists, we can think about
better ways to build molecules
that are important for
making medications.
Another thing we can do is we
can use our chemistry to
understand biological systems,
so we can help illucinate
pathways, maybe, that are
implicated in disease.
So, the combination of these
two things had made my
decision and I ended up coming
here for graduate school,
actually, and working in
Professor Imperiali's lab
doing bio-organic chemistry,
which means that I synthesize
molecules, which I loved,
and used them to
study biological systems.
So, really I'm pretty happy with
what I've gotten to do,
and I just want to say we're not
trying to convert all of
them you pre-med people,
by any means.
My roommate for many years was
going to medical school as I
was going to graduate school,
and we found we had so many
interesting conversations about
chemistry -- her from
the context of practicing and
using medications and talking
about how they worked on a
molecular level, and me
talking about my research.